all right so I'd like to do a little bit
of recap each time that we do this in
part because I want you to be able to
see how these different perspectives are
coming together to differentiate and
apart from each other
you notice that gap in on this therapy
this listing of participants in the
Republic I've got a couple kisum's
couple different world theories listed
that's because at this point you guys
have been introduced to three different
moral theories introduced we haven't
gone into them at any great depth but
you've been introduced to them you've
also been introduced to sort of a
traditional conception which we don't
actually have a name for so we're
looking at book four right today and
that's focusing on the parts of the soul
that's actually going to give us the
beginnings of Socrates own perspective
Plato's moral theory which is a type of
virtue ethics we're going to talk a lot
about virtue today not a term that
you're used to hearing except we have
some very restricted circumstances those
of you who grew up Catholic or in
certain Protestant denominations may
have heard the term in part because of
the Catechism or the moral theory that
uses those terms and they talk about
virtues but you may still not have any
idea what where she is
we're in a society that uses virtue
language but doesn't use the word virtue
and we'll talk more about it but first
what sort of Greek character so we
started out in book 1 with this guy
Marcus catalases son remember he
inherited the argument capitalist
shuffle off the scene as soon as
Socrates asking a difficult question
what is justice and what a bull market
say so well this guy's Simona DS you
know famous poet said justice is giving
people what is their due
yeah there's really two kinds of people
in life there is brass identities
what should you get friends dude sweet
closes left if anything let's take a
blind you're okay yeah okay
you got friends right what she gave her
friends put this otherwise they're not
gonna do friends very long right he
doesn't say they after this makes sense
and friends you know intend good to you
right that's how you know they're
friends so friends are good people and
enemies are bad people
we've all met enemies right we've had
enemies at one point or another
yeah an elementary school middle school
high school it could have been a kid
that you just didn't get along with on
the playground and be getting into this
rap could have been somebody spreading
rumors about you behind your back
it could have been somebody competing
with you over the same things that you
liked it could have been competing for
approval it could have been competing
for the boy or the girl who you were
interested in it could have been
competing to be the best in some some
athletic than it could have been
competing to be the best in some
academic thing what do you do what do
you get tenant what do they deserve bad
things right
does this sound you know fairly common
sensical
yeah every society has a version of this
think about you know that the Golden
Rule do you want to others of you and
you have them do to you
well you know does that mean you have to
be nice different buddy all the time
because is there any way to twist up
when your mom or dad said that's it you
have to try to get you to that nice yeah
follow you could be the one not very
nice therefore you get it back
you can say I don't have any problem
with somebody you know I act the fool
knocking me down I'd like somebody to do
that so I quit acting like a jerk
therefore I'm gonna do this in this
person some of these rules don't don't
you know they don't achieve what they're
intended to be possibly similar to the
eye for an eye tooth for a tooth
philosophy isn't it you don't heard that
before somebody crosses you what should
you do somebody hurts you further back
that's what they deserve so that's if
you're saying they deserve it
that's justice somebody kills your
cousin kill their cousin this is the way
a lot of ancient societies function in
societies that don't have what we call
rule of law
somebody's talks about you behind your
back maybe you don't have to do exactly
that maybe you can do something else
like
find some incriminating photos of that
someone's over there and applause but
under that under this sort of you know
that would be a perfectly just thing to
do with them
so this is one view of how to behavior
how you want to be thinking about that
how to be an ethical person as a matter
of fact if this is the right way then
what about somebody who forgives people
too easily
wouldn't that what's going on there how
many of you did you've all been hurt by
people right plenty of times new one how
many of you when you were hurt wrongly
you didn't have it coming to you he had
somebody else who told you that you
should get over it or that the other
person really isn't that bad that this
is uncharacteristic of them that you
need to be the bigger man a bigger woman
and for ya everybody how did you feel
about that how many of you forget which
is which is a bad thing
how many of you felt kind of says it the
second harm had been done to you but
being told you should take these attacks
you're right there's there's a lot of
circumstances this is a very deeply
rooted conception of justice there's a
reason why every culture every society
has some version of this we want to try
to get beyond this because this by
itself is importantes putting out some
problems with that
but it's understandable if somebody was
there it's understandable if that was
the way somebody reason Tristan I guess
comes on the scene and some of this is
much more radical isn't it do you say
things like justice is just the interest
of the stronger the the weak are a bunch
of sheep to be fleeced by the shepherd
then how does he treat Socrates it's not
very nice and conversation is it he kind
of represents his long philosophy he's a
German
he tries to impose his will on everybody
else he actually doesn't want to say
anything until they give us one you guys
to get something from them right it's
all about taking taking taking or
imposing on other people that's a common
frame - is it when you got hurt by
somebody in the past you might have been
somebody likes for some ACCA's there are
people out there who espouses
everybody's just out there to use
everybody else so if that's really the
case what should you do you should try
to claw your way to the top right if
it's just about having power you'd be a
dummy not just weak you know deserving
of that word again deserving deserving
it being treated badly if you don't
actually assert yourself that's true so
my kisses position we can identify this
with what we thought ego is the egoism
is a moral theory we haven't talked
about this in great detail the egoism is
one of those moral theories out there
that says what's good do even satisfies
your desires your desires not his
desires not my desires your desires
now of course how do I see it what's
good is what satisfies my desires and
that happens against
desires too bad thrills your screw you
know so if I don't want to charge that I
have an egoist I'm gonna set things up
so that they work out really great for
me you know like you know it wouldn't be
any problem for if I was an egoist to
think that I should exploit my students
that maybe maybe what I do is I give you
the assignments that later on I'm going
to use and cobble together it's gonna
block I'm not gonna give you any credit
or any money or anything like that
because you know they're to be used
right and you know if you want to be on
equal terms with me you can find some
way we can work out some mutually
agreeable arrangement whereby I use you
and you use me that sound good
like you know princessy a little
cutthroat well in some circumstances it
will get cut through especially if
there's a lot of competition over the
same good because let's think about it
in terms of that I want some money
I want to be curved I want to get my
point across and let's say it's that
classroom work it's mostly be talking to
do this just responding let's say we're
just doesn't have any conversation and I
want to talk to get my point across but
that cuts into your time and he's not
even being heard from and he's not
getting in his time at all and these two
would like to talk just as much as
Whedon would so you know we might like
team up just to shut him up and then
then once we've done that now it's you
and me right it could get Mary Katherine
resources again cut from our prestige
all the things that matter to us the
perspective of egoism says that really
there there aren't any restrictions in
and of themselves on what counts as you
know satisfying my interests what would
be good for me we might agree on those I
might you know not act a jerk but for
instance I am dependent on you in a
certain respect right how do you have a
power over me in suits not much but I
don't feel bad the younger dudes show
it's any of your classes administration
I look at that as maybe yeah other than
the teaching other than that it means
you've other recourses right you fill
out evaluations at the end of the
semester right yeah I had a friend back
at my old school and I don't know what
he did to this class he was kind of an
arrogant guy but he didn't deserve what
happened to his students teamed up and
when I came to evaluation time you know
the professor leaves the classroom right
I don't know if I'm here but that's the
way it's been done every place that I
and the students got together and they
said let's screw this guy yeah I think
probably one of those cases where three
or four the students were very upset and
the rest of
okay that's that's fine with me
and I really like this guy particularly
and they all gave it very little
evaluations
well those get used to decide whether
you get promoted with tenure all sorts
of things along those lines and of
course you know when your evaluations
come in they're already the ball your
boss wants to know what's going on what
did you do these students that made them
so angry so that's that's one when you
can also go refight professor calm right
although now I think you have to have an
account in order to to use it looked at
some of my peers and I've looked at my
my own for my old school some of them
are kind of funny one one person one
student they actually wrote in the
comments that I was lenient but strictly
this isn't a critical thinking class
lenient but strict what is the problem
with strict being not giving anything so
I think they wanted to compliment you
know three ways with the cuts to go
together
they say it'd be like saying smart yet
stupid so but yeah you could you could
we could work out some sort of deal
professors do this sort of thing where
they saying I'm gonna make it really
easy on you and you're gonna give me
good evaluations and that can be done
for me Diego's perspective right when
you when you get into your career you
might find something that works out like
that but one of the things that goes
along with this is you only consider
your perspective or the act of others
who can can affect your desires so
everybody else forget about them so we
might get together and make a business
deal and benefit both a meeting and view
but you know screw all the consumers or
the
who are financing or things like along
those lines so that dents made it a
moral theory it's not a moral theory a
sense that it's you know very moral to
act that way but this is one way in
which people make sense out of right and
wrong and it's just a very low level
isn't what would be your acceptance into
be good to other people you want to get
something from them that's it or you
don't want them to hurt you so if you
really angry at somebody don't kill them
why not because killings a bad thing or
because you'd be taking their their life
away and then along with that all the
other things that could happen just cuz
you don't want to go to prison right
because we're going to prison would be a
bad thing that would be equally so
that's that's the true cynic is this
position Lofton is is taking a position
that gets us past egoism and towards
something that we call contract areas
there's a long fancy word for saying
we've got some sort of arrangement that
we work out in society and that
arrangement we for the most part we
don't actually make that arrangement we
come to it and were raised in it and
it's already there you know for instance
we were talking before class began about
New York and got lost
apparently in New York it's illegal even
to have to have a pistol in your hand
unless you have a permit for that's not
the case in Indiana where I was living
or North Carolina where I was living but
it is the case of New York why is that
the case here because people pass that
as a law why do you think they did that
we were talking a little bit about
yeah so you can't hide the gun in your
pocket there anywhere else
Shoob anyone whereas a shotgun you can't
that's harder to them I mean you can't
oh you mean like a trench coat yeah yeah
the idea was it was supposed to cut down
on crime by removing one of the things
that is typically involved in crimes by
making that legal why should we follow
that if I don't have a gun but I don't
actually have anything against guns
why shouldn't I get a pistol and walk
around this you know keep it in my
pocket side holster or something like
that well not just because they they
could send me to jail for their
retention prison I'm assuming it's a
felony yeah that's some kind of serious
thing right that would be egoist yal
shouldn't I do that well because I'd be
breaking the law and I'd be disrupting
public water and I'd be sort of
upsetting the arrangement that we have
and I should care about them not because
I really love justice for its own sake
but because the you know the panel of
the the what happens if I start breaking
the social contract if I start violating
the norms you might start doing it too
if enough people start breaking the
rules which protect us all then the
rules are going to fall apart aren't
they
and that would that would be bad because
that
you know we always actually like to be
committing unjustice remember we talked
about this is the RIT Tigers last class
if you have a spring that turned you
visible how many of you would be you
know resisting the opportunity to take
revenge of your enemies to steal money
to have whatever you want that would be
a very difficult thing to resist Lockett
is saying look you know we really do
have all these desires for other
people's stuff to take advantage of
people like through something that's the
same but we get together and we say okay
I'm not going to do that to you and
you're not going to do that to me and we
don't do it individually we do it as a
society and that's what was our you know
think about we use traffic and speed
limits last classes in example how many
of you think that it's okay to thrive
five over the speed limit
how many do you think that it's okay to
drive ten of those people in that child
fuel us how many of you think it's okay
to drive as fast as you want
well what know now why you know what's
the difference between driving ten over
and driving say thirty oh how is it
different for you well the reason why
they say it's that you know my driving
special because to me I mean if you're
speeding your speed it doesn't matter if
it's five ten over twenty over yeah you
hear speeding around you're speeding so
I mean even you have to do that if you
break the rule you break the rule and
that's and that's it and that's
understandable what about the rest of
you why do you why did you say was okay
to drive ten over but now thirty yeah
whistle blowing spit French 25 go
thinner D at nine Devon go reckless
driving moves my license
okay so it's based out of egoistic
anybody else have any other reasons yeah
kill someone when you could kill
somebody driving the speed limit right
waited for your more lighting like yeah
so the greater the impact the driving
like 65 forget it right yeah okay so
you're doing sort of credential we call
straight calculating things about odds
of people getting hurt let's seem to do
this a large-scale plus we're actually
coming to some sort of agreement clearly
none of us respect the traffic laws as
they are we all feel they're too
restrictive right but there is some sort
of boundary for how how much wiggle room
there is at least with this classroom we
feel except with the exception of one
person which you know and that's not a
bad position to take fifty miles an hour
over you say yeah break it there's not
really much of a difference between five
and ten but that's what I was about over
but that's what I'm saying right that's
what's interesting there is a difference
belt by most of the people in the class
there's some sort of window ten over
okay
fine but if you're going more than that
now you're really acting recklessly
you're violating something it's not
actually the law of the land it's more
like something but we we feel and we
agree to I mean I asked you to think
about this before how many of you could
hear it stated with people in the left
lane who aren't breaking the speed limit
right that's kind of strange isn't we're
getting angry at people for following
the law why what is it about the left
lane that makes us feel like this person
is a jerk for sitting there 55 because
the what play is supposed to do the
passive way yes person the right way is
going slow you're supposed to pass them
when they go back to the right way so
tell us wants to go fast
nobody can so again you know there is
there's sort of an agreement among us
right this way is okay to act this way
isn't okay that the left lane is for
this right
that's contract terminal that is we have
these rules and these agreements and if
we follow them we're doing the right
thing because if we break them we're
being unjust and they could be based on
some sort of ego as thing ultimately but
the contract here nism goes beyond
because we're going to get to virtue
ethics next with Socrates I want to talk
a little bit about this term in virtue
ethics so how many of you heard this
term encourage you before probably the
religious context just a few okay would
avert how many heard that your vice vice
is the opposite of virtue what what do
you do the associated vices let's start
with that what's it mice like my
interpretation is something that brings
you good but it doesn't have any like
productive to your wellness or anything
like
good decision great happy you got a
pretty good happiness or that doesn't
really serve like a moral purpose okay
let's say you know you like drinking
drinking money pretty happiness you may
or may not be acceptable but yeah it
doesn't it certainly doesn't progression
above me yeah well oh you say enough to
drink a glass of wine per day it's
supposed to be good so maybe some some
drinking in moderation moderation is a
virtue we have to think of like no
drinking or smoking gambling as a vice
right and what else frequenting
prostitutes to play have isopods those
are the things that we typically call
Isis fights in it in its traditional
sense means any sort of bad disposition
and they have that's something that you
don't just do once you never do again
it's something it's a disposition it's a
part of your character so if I'm greedy
for example you've all heard of the
seven deadly sins right we seven
probably name the right greed loss sloth
you know right
those are vices originally they were
called the eighty capital vices and this
got changed a long way actually the
video where I discussed this if you're
interested in this sort of thing because
people are always fast and could eat
become salmon you know how do they come
up with these lists well these are these
are dispositions that make people
according to virtue ethics ban people
greedy person you can count on them to
behave in greedy ways what would be the
opposite of being greedy
yeah generous generosity generosity is a
virtue that has to do with given what
you're willing to give now it's
interesting because you could you could
be stingy and not give anything right
that's advice you could be generous when
you give a certain amount what if you
give way too much is that is that
generosity that becomes something they
had again yeah part of the vices an
extreme form of something like wrath
extreme anger anger sometimes in
moderation yeah sloth yeah you're right
vices are a form of extreme we're gonna
get through this more when we want to
read Aristotle which is going to happen
fairly soon
I just want introduced to the general
concept so virtues are the opposite
they're good character traits they're
not just things that you do wants in a
while by the way one of the virtues that
supposed to the greediness is justice
greed is wanting to have more than your
fair share right you want the whole cake
not just your piece of the cake you want
what you've got and what your neighbor
has that's more than your fair share
justice is wanting to give people their
fair share want to be have your fair
share because it's open virtues you have
to do not just with how you behave but
also of how you think and how you feel
so if you do the right thing only
because somebody compels you you're not
actually purchase because as soon as
they put they quit compelling you what's
gonna happen
think about kids think about kids and
greed and then generosity right there's
a cake and there's twelve kids and one
of the kids gets to slice the cake
somebody isn't there to make sure that
that kid actually gives everybody a
piece of cake
what's gonna happen somebody's gonna get
less cake or no cake right now after a
while we develop these habits and then
you can leave the kid alone in the room
and then the kid you know will come to
desire wanting to give it everybody
their fair share and some start out like
that right
some kids are seem to be naturally good
that way though there's others you can
you can train them as much as you want
they always seem to be kind of vicious
don't they but these virtues and vices
deserve these are part of our character
so we measure whether somebody is doing
the right thing or not by how much what
they're doing exhibits virtue or is part
of promoting virtue and on the other
yeah if what they're doing is promoting
vice like if I'm being a bad example to
you I'm not modeling to you the way say
somebody ought to approach these texts
if I come in and I'm real sloppy and
then what I'm talking about
I mentioned making you worse aren't I
I'm giving you a bad model to follow I'm
leading you in this advice that would be
bad now before we actually look at
Socrates stop let's think about some of
these these cases these are fairly easy
cases to decide to these these things on
line you know well the ethos would say
it really depends doesn't it am I gonna
get hurt if I lie to people if not then
it's okay for me to lie especially if it
gets me what I want what about a
contract Harriet
you know who's concerned with keeping
order and society and having a you know
social matrix in which we can depend on
each other how would they see my babies
sometimes good sometimes bad
well they wouldn't say that because
people need to live okay if there's if
there's sort of a general social
expectation that you tell the truth
violating that social expectation would
be would be bit later on in the semester
we're going to try to imagine whether we
have a society in which it was okay to
lie all the time but most societies say
no you shouldn't lie as a matter of fact
a lot of them to me and you to tell the
truth in certain times virtue ethicists
it's gonna say lying is we had to in
general because we don't think about
being a liar I think someone who can't
be relied on to tell the truth that's a
vicious disposition isn't it did if you
want to live with the wire you're going
to marry a liar
how about being a business person does
this burger of the pathological liar
all these we have to do sales right they
don't lie to you but if they're but if
they're a liar that's a problem if
they're lying to customers they're gonna
lie to you - you know that's similar to
the issue of if you get into a
relationship with somebody by stealing
them away from their spouse you know and
they're willing to cheat on their spouse
they're probably really good sheet on
you you know these things are rooted in
our character stealing again the egoist
otherwise hey it's okay through cinema
kisses say you can get away with it do
it contract Arianism can you have a
society where where people are violating
the norm of stealing how do we usually
treat people who steal what social order
brings down
that's what they do in societies where
they still have social order they just
have a very harsh social order DQ
looters right get up on top your store
and you shoot up as they're trying to
get into your store one of the reasons
why prisons are in some ways more humane
out on the frontier you know how they
dealt with with theft
you hate peaceful you kill them if
somebody was you know breaking if
somebody was violating the social order
and doing it you know you know waiver
use depended on them to do it next week
too
they're too dangerous to leave around
like they're killing somebody they're
killing somebody you probably to do that
too right virtue of this is it purchased
to be a thief we have movies that make
it seem like that one is 12 we don't
want to live next to the thief virtue
ethics you know one way of thinking
about whether something is a virtue or
advice
this may sound kind of silly but would
you like to live next to a person like
that would you allow that person
somebody like that to marry into your
family if you have a choice you know who
would you like to have in your family
you'd like to have people who don't
steal right maybe even when they find
your wallet on the street they don't
just turn it into the law found a they
look at it and they say oh I know who
this belongs I'm gonna go take it to
them we can skip over the rest whatever
what I thought when we get to these more
difficult ones like st. Bronx right and
then we have to be like bribing a judge
let's say it's a matter of you're
getting hired all you want to get a job
right competition is very
you're jealous
what if you take the person who's hiring
out for lunch you know some talk about
the requirements of the job you say you
know they said well I don't know I'm not
quite comfortable with this but I'll go
along with you anyway have anything you
want Mike I just want to get you here to
talk about now you know that if you're
giving yourself a bit of an edge not
everybody's doing what does it really
want I mean you know from an Igor's
perspective yeah do it all those other
people are dummies if they're not do it
again right and that person obviously is
getting something out of it if they're
sitting there across from you know from
a contract area if it's if it's bribing
judges and subverting though that you
know the courts and stuff like that that
can't be taller what about you know what
seems to be much more innocent you know
or great area right I don't know what
does that cost so in order to break down
if I take somebody out to lunch need
something like something that is popular
because they if you're in sales you know
everybody tries to say to a potential
client all the noise
lots dinner or you know I'll advise you
to this big rooftop party in there you
know on the largest you're right people
do that stuff all the time
that amendment where it gets bad is when
it affects people not within that party
yeah like for instance like judge that
took bribe to send kids to juvenile
detention centers yeah you know I mean
so I think there's kind of like the
social norm where we think it's
acceptable and they kind of someone
refunds within the two parties okay well
and it actually does
politics - in our society their lobbying
and all sorts of things along those
lines
the local state and federal a virtue
ethicist taking bribes doesn't really
matter what it is it's not that taking
bribes in and of itself is automatically
wrong another perspective we're going to
look at later on the semesters gonna say
that what kind of character does a
person have who is willing to prefer
others for a launch is that the kind of
person that you look up to well that's
that's going the other way around yeah
you know that could be an interesting
one to look at it well sometimes
sometimes you know there are these cases
every once in a while where so many
athletes give them way more than they
possibly should have been given by some
coach and the coaches disciplined and
then the question gets debated doesn't
that sports channels and in Sports
Illustrated well is this really wrong
this is the way it knows you know
somebody say somebody says it is wrong
another person says it isn't wrong
you've got a moral disagreement there
I'm gonna sketch up three Socrates's
position yeah Socrates is drawing this
parallel and this is chapter between the
city and he is sketching out an ideal
city right
you've got the rulers the guardians and
you've got
let's call them soldiers because these
lesser guardians of any have the traits
and each one of these is important I
think they all have their roles they all
have their their jobs what makes them do
their job well what what consists in
their their function what makes them
stay on track
what do they give to the city it's not
just doing something once in a while
it's a it's a state of character it's a
habit and have a personal character that
the rulers job is wisdom or walking the
calmness prunex being able to figure out
what want to be done I mean if a ruler
is a good ruler they shouldn't just be
flying by the seat of their pants they
should actually have some plans ahead of
time so we're going to deal with this
problem how we're going to reconcile all
these people who can't seem to get along
with each other to each other how we're
going to promote justice within the city
all right how we're going to be fair how
we're gonna look ahead works for likely
issues come on what about soldiers
what's the biggest thing that soldiers
need besides weapons yeah turret right
because if you have weapons but you
don't encourage you're actually harming
your enemy as soon as you drop that
weapon they're gonna pick it up this is
why you know it's not going to great
ideas on our homeless citizens against
the crime you know if you you like to
carry a knife you don't have the guts to
use it and somebody attacks you you just
given them a knife because they'll take
it away from
is that so the soldiers name current it
has courage something that you just sort
of happen into what do we do with our
soldiers just try to promote courage war
what do we do exactly
yeah boot camp for the Marines from Navy
people I think right basic training for
the Army out on the Air Force house
and they're very similar you're right
there's a process of breaking people
down and you drill them and then you
build their morale back up and you also
put them into dangerous situations like
I remember a basic one of the things
that we had to do which I didn't
actually find all that that daunting is
some of those people yeah was we had to
crawl under machine-gun fire through
barbed wire and you know things blowing
up you know around us but I can't like
that sort of thing
what I thought scary was they had to
rappel off a tower that I don't fear
Heights and I actually this is kind of
interesting digression women hint
somebody yelling it and saying I'm gonna
throw you off this tower if you don't
get off my tower you know I could do it
I was scared but I can think of jumping
off the rappel and I did it several
times after that while I was in the
military I got out of the military and a
friend of mine said hey let's go
rappelling I notice that this great
bridge and we can do it okay I'll do
that and I jump off then my hand would
just seize up well there wasn't anybody
pushing me to do it turned out I didn't
really have
because if I really had courage I could
have continued the repellent right we
want soldiers to actually heaven who
else do we want together
he doesn't talk so much about this but
yeah
fireman yeah I mean to go into a
building that's actually on fire
it's totally encumber than a whole bunch
of stuff that's you know that's the
irrational behavior but it's done for
something good which makes it rational
and what why would you done what else
yeah
policeman yeah let's cover the whole
thing prison guards especially the
prisons and we'll leave it we'll leave
it here
whether anybody else needs courage I
think that actually all of you need
courage whether you be cops firemen
soldiers about trans people trace people
are not the rulers and that you know
comical soldiers out there they're just
people are earning a living what are the
one of the temptations that they're
gonna be subject green one right taking
too much what they need is what's called
temperance or moderation you know if you
want to be a good electrician you can't
be a drunk okay and you know people
drums because they like to drink because
it's enjoyable drinking is pleasant and
doctors I mean the hangover thanks David
sometimes and when you first start doing
it you may not like the taste of some
things
when you first taste your dance beer you
know you open it up and bring it out to
menu tasting so can anybody drink this
it's a whoreo but you get older and then
you get the taste for gonna get me the
first whiskey that's long it's terrible
stuff but then you learn how to
appreciate it right and once you do now
you're going to watch out because
drinking feels good and it's fun and if
you do too much you're gonna keep doing
too much aren't you you set up habits
there's a there's a added thing here oh
the drink is alcohol is actually
addicting but you know we can
distinguish a psychological addiction
which is a matter of concern of that but
you know if the tradespeople are
drinking too much or the traits people
are greedy or if the tradespeople
are you know what are other pleasures
that lead us astray if they're lazy
because there's you know spending too
much time in bed they're not gonna
fulfill their task well are they so they
need moderation everybody else does too
and then according to Socrates when you
have all these classes having these
things and they're all allowed to do
their job you have justice everybody is
getting to do of the attributes of
justice is a kind of apartment inside of
the city right and people who promote
that would be just people people who
know I guess it would be unjust people
what about human being here's where it
gets really interesting
we can't see our souls right there's a
very funny that all of these are the new
remake of the Planet of the Apes I'm not
talking about the one that just came up
or the one I came out about eight nine
years ago had Tim Roth Annette Martin
Wahlberg yeah he's the he's the trial to
Destin character in it
Tim Roth is this gorilla and he's a he's
an army general and you know Percy hates
humans and you know he's supposed to be
a typical big there's a really great
line in there Mark Wahlberg is like one
of the servants at that time and they're
having a debate as people do have dinner
parties about you know well you know
these servants of Mars that they have
souls are not some people they don't say
no they they don't they're just dirty
animals look at oh they don't even have
hair and Tim Roth's character grabs Mark
Wahlberg over the scene right and he
pulls open his mouth and he like looks
at the citing says I don't see a soul in
here and pushes him away and that's
supposed to ask the conversation we've
often imagined you know I'm going to
talk about the soul is something like
you've all seen movies where somebody
gets it's him they die out-of-body
experience you see this kind of ghostly
things floating sometimes it's in
cartoons
sometimes it's seen along some sci-fi
thing this whole looks like the body
except this is kind of see-through yeah
that's what the person really isn't
their bodies laying there just like meat
right dead meat well what what would be
in there well what actually would be
going on that would be who the person
really is right because they're not that
slab of meat
what's in a salt what makes you you
other than you know wearing certain
clothes and having certain appearance
which is gonna change them and change
overnight
you know dye your hair you gain weight
lose weight bulk up lose your muscles
you know if you're a good athlete can
actually change that we walk we sound
you project it makes you you something
something different we would often talk
about it not necessarily as a soul but
as a personality right all of you have a
personality for better for worse like my
personality it might not like my
personality but I've got all right it's
we all have well is it all one big thing
does every action that you're involved
in every everything that you think about
everything you desire does it use the
whole thing
or maybe could there be parts of you if
you ever had the experience of being
undecided being torn between two
different things not being able to
decide what to do like maybe you felt
competing loyalties to your family and
to your friends or you attempted to do
something and it was bad boy it was
tempting
well Socrates says if that's the case
then there must be different parts
because the same thing can't be acting
or feel that you're doing the two
different ways at the same time right
think about this one he'd be facing this
way I'm fixing that way at the same time
maybe if you have actually had the
proverbial eyes in the back so what do
we know that we do together so that's
where the three starts and if you desire
anything
everybody has goals but I think I think
it goes along the buddy system would you
call values like we value getting
ourselves and then others that really
leaves so part character what do you
like about other people think that most
people are good caring you know I got
trying to get along ok so those are
things that you desire you know that
people probably things you desire about
yourself right probably one of the
people that all that here that way yeah
that's gonna get us actually to this and
that's sort of the second level
let's work at the real base level why do
I drink coffee helps me stay awake so I
need to be drinking coffee I could be
drinking you know for our energy or you
know taking caffeine pills
I like it exactly I like to taste it
it pleases me I have desire when I get
up in the morning and there's no coffee
left
alright ticked off who forgot to buy
coffee so I can get ticked off at myself
whilst we have designers like that
hungry right
what does our body tell us weed we
should do how many of you're going to go
back to your your door or something like
that I'm taking in if you go get
probably more than that are copping to
it
I would if I could myself so I'll go
work we desire to do that sort of stuff
we desire to lay in the Sun something
like feels good on our skin we desire
not to be cold that's why you would be
sunbathing right now all right we have
all sorts of desires and Socrates
a word that's bone appetite appetite for
one can desire for things that please us
or don't please us know sometimes of our
desire is to get rid of something that
that's hurting us like when you're
really hungry you're not just looking
forward to the taste of the food you
want that yeah you know that hurted your
belly to stop right now caring what
other people think about us
that's at a different level that's not
just at the level of satisfying basic
appetites and desires he's got a word
here that in Greek that's very difficult
to translate and so we often say some
something like the spirited captioning
part this is the part mystic it's
angular2 not angry like you know
somebody forgot to buy coffee but
somebody forgot to buy coffee and they
should have and I'm put up by it and
that shows that they don't care about me
that they think they're better than me
you know when we get angry we get angry
not just because we don't have some some
need that you know it couldn't have it's
working you didn't give me my food or
place in the Sun or you're interrupting
my sleep but we really get angry because
we care about the way before perceive us
and when somebody does something wrong
to us we think AHA now I know how you
really feel about me I don't matter to
you at all do i or are lower than you
think you're better than me that's why
we get angry we feel slighted we feel
that the other person has lower this
this is also the part of us that
competes for and to be honored by other
people
to be respected by the people often
demands that you put your desires whole
alright all of us we have one of the
designers we haven't talked about so far
sexual desire right everybody wants to
have sex and they don't just want to
have sex once they want to have sex many
many times throughout their life right
can consensual desire get you in trouble
anybody ever been in a relationship and
even though the relationship was bad
because the sex was good I was a long
time ago I went to college why do we do
that why do we why don't we do stupid
things along those lines
well here's where we get to another you
know what would actually tell us that's
a bad idea reason you think about thing
to say wait a second this isn't good for
me I'm not getting anything out of this
lesson I remember actually had I even I
broke up with somebody as a New Year's
resolution
she was very surprised and it was
because you know it was a bad
relationship and I reasoned it out that
you know New Year's this is the one time
of the year where you start saying what
am i doing you know before you got them
to start the party
what am I doing with this this is this
is not what I want at all I don't see
myself you know with this person a year
from now but I do it you know
so I reasoned it out and Reason can
impose appetite or desire if you are
trying to diet your body wants to eat
right reason can't save you
I want to lose X amount of pounds I can
only do that if I actually die is what
we call practical reasoning therefore I
must not follow this designer so reason
can do that and reason is not
all that that passion one second we also
do that for this is part of our soul all
that is concerned with honor with soft
respect with how we feel about ourselves
the part of us that gets angry we put
things on hold for that you don't go out
and satisfy every sexual desire that
you've got in part because you care
about what people think about you right
you would like people to respect you
because you know I mean you're human
beings like everybody else
right and these can oppose each other
sometimes the appetites can so dominate
a person that they bring everything else
in one extreme example is addiction
somebody is addicted to drugs or are
addicted to alcohol or them you know I
mean I know if it's a real disorder that
you want to debate about this sexual
addiction but certainly food addictions
aren't their addictive behavior with
respect to food that's where the
appetite takes over and makes all the
other parts of the soul sub-circuits
that's like at the city trainings people
take over you can also have the soldiers
take over can't you you can have that
part of your soul that is obsessed with
you know honor and respect and stuff
like that that could dominate reason to
good the reason tells you what the good
thing to do is and what the bad thing to
do is sometimes just doing what you feel
like when you're angry then this is his
anger always a really good guide to what
you want to be doing
what does anger make you do something
yeah like what like going on buying a
latte for your your your partner no what
kind of impulsive things that you're
very angry follow that when you're
yelling at somebody yeah
and who do we know is anybody depends on
how person are some people just see out
the person next moment people you have
the person actually and yeah yeah that's
true some people their anger suppose all
over impulse principle Thanks clearly
going down reasons right and what they
actually be rationally yell at the
person that you're angry at hey Rach I
don't like it isn't necessarily the best
thing to like you know abuse them with
all sorts of follow language maybe not
that would be up to reason to decide
what does the spirited part of passion
say about that yes
or maybe hit them you know or if you
can't act right away maybe tell people
bad stuff about them maybe yes that
sometimes put on like a real nice face
then you can get back at them later that
could be a good thing to do but you know
usually it's not is it reasonably
telling that what is it what is the
spirit tell you
hell yeah do it it doesn t have the
capacity to regulate itself and a
society where the soldiers are in charge
does they have the capacity
to keep certain things in check to
soldiers make really good rulers usually
they tend to look out just for their own
interest only part of why we try to
avoid military dictatorships States
we're you know we're talking about
dieting and keeping I figured about one
could still eat but they could just work
out more or you're right any doing by
saying that you are reached your you're
fighting alternate ways to make the same
desired effect take place or one can eat
more but less calories like a
maintenance ninety calories have been
eight boys that's thirty calories so I
can be sudden ability to run
constructive elements again using the
reason the part of your soul that does
that does does your hunger distinguish
between any of that sort of stuff that
that part of your soul doesn't just as
eat eat that eat that
that looks good to have some of that
reason is what allows you to say that's
got so many calories that's okay for me
that it's got too many that's not okay
for me and reason if you're if you're if
you did your body and your soul are
working on it then all three of these
partners work together
yeah is what will make you into it just
person a person who is you know
integrated a person who has a permanent
if your appetites dominates you if you
you know think about Indiana cars are
there any are there any heroine addicts
or crackheads
as who you would rely on to be just in
their dealings with other people no what
do they do what a methods do to feed
their addiction how do they usually get
themselves in trouble it's not by to
play being a mouth itself the cop comes
along you're on meth taking you in
what do they do
yeah that's the number one day they
steal sometimes they kill people they
try to log on if it goes bad you know of
course math will make you aggressive too
I guess one of the benefits of hero and
other math design people on heroin just
lay around people are looking for things
to do you know so if we had to choose
what to dig people do is we pick error
but it's not a good thing is it because
we're gonna their appetites are gonna
dominate what if this part is is in
charge that's the guy who gets in bar
fights whether it needs to or not or
that's the the more subtle warrior the
friend the one who you know puts on the
face of being your friend so they can
get close to you then takes you down
because what they're really about is
being on top you know through some I
guess this is kind of a person along
those lines isn't they and people who
talk like you're send kiss very often
are dominated by this part of their soul
they don't just want to get you know
left these is them whether it's you know
food or sacks or you know comfort or
something like that they want to be in
charge they want to
people they want to have power they want
to be looked up to and they want more
than reason wood would say and so they
will they will probably be unjust they
will do long things and we see it
through cinema kisses case not only
leads to being um just look at the way
he talks to Socrates you know he's
actually talking to his elder in these
cases and he's talking to me like they
think he's an idiot he's actually saying
this is the way we ought to be and one
of the things that you could think about
the wonderful thing about this for us is
much presenting that we just put reason
in charge and let that run the whole
show yeah
nice